[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale nous
sommes à Djerba où se tient le 18e
sommet de la Francophonie notre invité
aujourd'hui et sa secrétaire général
louise Mushikiwabo bonjour madame
secrétaire général bonjour Marc et avec
moi pour cette interview Laurent Corot
de RFI bonjour Louise mouche
donc ce sommet se tient ici en Tunisie
avec deux ans de retard en 2020 c'était
en raison de la pandémie en 2021 c'était
en raison de la situation politique
compliquée ici en Tunisie un an plus
tard la situation s'est clarifiée mais
dans le sens que beaucoup appellent un
recul démocratique à savoir la
concentration des pouvoirs entre les
mains du président KS Saïd on sait que
l'une des missions de la Francophonie
est justement la promotion de la
démocratie alors est-ce que ce n'est pas
un mauvais signal de venir ici en
Tunisie vu le contexte politique
alors moi je suis très heureuse que ce
sommet de Djerba est finalement et lieu
oui
tout le monde n'est pas du même avis sur
les critères
démocratiques et c'est vrai on doit être
honnête aussi que les changements
politiques en Tunisie ont été profonds
mais en même temps
nous avons aujourd'hui plusieurs pays de
l'espace francophone et ailleurs ou
on ne peut pas vraiment mesurer la
vie démocratique pour moi et je ne suis
pas je ne suis pas en tant que
secrétaire général d'un francophonie la
personne qui décide d'où se tient le
sommet ce sont les chefs ce sont les
états et gouvernement mais pour moi
puisque j'ai mon opinion aussi
j'ai surtout suivi
la température des citoyens tunisiens et
oui il y a eu beaucoup de
protestations au niveau du pays surtout
la classe politique mais j'ai trouvé que
la population tunisienne était plutôt
apaisé à accepter
en grande partie c'est pas tout le monde
encore une fois
et donc pour moi ce sommet à
lieu
dans ce pays qui est aussi c'est un
critère qu'il ne faudrait pas négliger
c'est le pays dans des pères fondateurs
de notre organisation alors si on avait
eu
voilà une une situation où tous les
Tunisiens sortent dans la rue etc ça
aurait été beaucoup plus compliqué mais
je dois dire que oui il y a eu des
protestations face à l'évolution
politique de ce pays mais je pense que
largement les Tunisiens pour différentes
raisons
ont accepté ce nouveau ce nouveau
paysage politique c'est vrai que c'est
des réformes assez profondes et donc
nous sommes heureux d'être ici à Djerba
et surtout de pouvoir tenir ce sommet
qui n'a pas pu avoir lieu depuis 2020
alors vous l'évoquez louise Mushikiwabo
la démocratie a subi des coûts très
dures la fin de la Francophonie ces
derniers mois il y a des pouvoirs
militaires de transition qui se sont
installés dans plusieurs pays au Mali au
Tchad au Burkina Faso en Guinée est-ce
que vous diriez que c'est une maladie de
l'espace francophone et que doit faire
l'OIF face à cette situation
alors d'abord c'est une situation qui me
désole moi en tant que secrétaire
général de la Francophonie parce que ce
sont nos pays membres mais en même temps
je crois qu'il faut être
[Musique]
réaliste par rapport à la situation
politique dans le monde je pense que je
ne me trompe pas si je dis que le monde
va mal et ça ça comprend le monde
francophone aussi nous avons d'autres
pays puisque vous parlez du continent
nous avons l'Éthiopie nous avons le
Mozambique à des pays francophones
ceci dit
les coups de temps qui reviennent sur le
continent c'est quand même perturbant ça
je dois dire
le passage
de la gestion d'un pays
de civils militaires et de suivi de
militaires à d'autres militaires ça
devient un peu
moi personnellement ça me désole parce
que ça crée une certaine instabilité au
niveau du pays et l'instabilité
politique ne permet pas d'avancer sur
d'autres plans à commencer par le plan
économique et en période aussi
compliquée économiquement tels que nos
pays l'ont vécu avec la pandémie
je crois j'espère en tout cas que on
doit tout faire et la francophonie l'OIF
en particulier joue son rôle là-dedans
il faudrait qu'on revienne un peu à la
normale alors en parlant d'un pays qui
est dans l'actualité pour de tristes
raisons le chat par exemple il y a des
événements tragiques le 20 octobre on
parle de entre 50 et 200 morts Leif a
sorti un communiqué le lendemain des
violences appelant au dialogues au calme
et tout ça on a quand même un petit peu
l'impression que c'est le service
minimum est-ce que vous êtes plus
impliqué pour tenter de résoudre cette
situation qui est exactement celle que
vous venez de décrire
pour le Tchad
[Musique]
depuis la crise nous avons j'ai dépêché
deux personnes qui ont travaillé depuis
le mois de mars aux côtés
des négociateurs qui étaient réunis à
Doha
nous avons
servi d'intermédiaire même plusieurs
fois entre différents groupes pour
essayer d'arriver à un minimum de
consensus pour amener certaines
personnalités
politiques militaire à la table des
négociations
je trouve que notre organisation de
toutes les crises que nous avons eu
cette année le Tchad et le pays où nous
avons beaucoup investi nous continuons
nous restons présents
que ce soit dans dans le chemin du
retour à la Constitution mais vous savez
ce ne sont pas des organisations
multilatérales ou internationales qui
vont changer la vie politique de nos
pays ce sont les dirigeants des pays et
ce sont les citoyens des pays nous
venons bien évidemment
en soutien nous venons en tant que
facilitateur parfois mais le sort
politique et autres de nos pays des
portes surtout de la qualité de la
gouvernance de nos dirigeants et que
doivent faire les dirigeants justement
pour que ça change prendre conscience
prendre conscience
de ce que ces changements qui sont quand
même assez brutaux des changements qui
arrivent les pays dont on parle les
coups d'État malheureuse situation au
Tchad vient s’ajouter à une situation
sécuritaire extrêmement grave nous avons
la situation sécuritaire nous avons la
crise économique qui a été très très
aiguë même par rapport à la crise
sanitaire et donc la nature même dans
dirigeant
c'est de
prendre conscience de l'importance de
son action à la tête du pays de pouvoir
bien coordonner les équipes politiques
surtout et ce sera le sujet du huis clos
politique de ce sommet il y a une
défiance citoyenne
dans le monde francophone et dans le
monde en général il faut une grande
prise de conscience aujourd'hui parlons
du chat justement est-ce qu'une
suspension de ce pays de l'oie est
envisagé est possible est-ce que vous la
souhaitez d'ailleurs vous
en coordination et en mot qui est très
important dans le monde multilatéral en
subsidiarité aux organisations qui sont
plus proches de la situation notamment
l'Union africaine la Communauté des
États de l'Afrique centrale et d'autres
organisations régionales et sous
régionale et donc nous sommes
constamment en échange avec avec ces
organisations soeurs et
nous attendons pour voir comment ces
organisations vont réagir pour le moment
au niveau de l'Union africaine je pense
que il y a plutôt une tendance à donner
ce que j'appelle une deuxième chance aux
autorités tchadiennes tout en restant
très vigilant en tout cas nous à l'if on
reste très vigilant par rapport à la
situation au Tchad ok donc ce n'est pas
exclu certains observateurs pensent que
porte moins d'attention à la défense de
la démocratie à la défense des droits de
l'homme et certains estiment que c'est
parce que vous venez d'un pays le Rwanda
qui est lui-même vivement critiqué par
les organisations des droits de l'homme
et que vous avez en quelque sorte
importer cette culture ici à
je
n'aime pas
être sur la défensive sur les questions
politiques ou de démocratie surtout pas
par rapport à mon pays dont je suis très
fière de la gouvernance politique et
autres
mais je crois encore une fois que les
responsabilités doivent être très
clairement définie
les décisions qui se prennent à l'oie
sont des décisions prises par les États
c'est comme ça que le multilatéral
fonctionne on convoque des réunions les
états sièges ils prennent des décisions
ça c'est c'est par rapport à la méthode
donc si les États dans leurs instances
n'arrivent pas à trouver une voie
commune en chemin clair je pense que la
responsabilité va aux États quant à
l'organisation qui est beaucoup plus
entre mes mains que que je dirige notre
travail politique et démocratique depuis
que je je suis là et c'est un livre
ouvert il n'y a rien rien à cacher nous
sommes une organisation depuis enfin
depuis que moi je suis là qui qui a été
très proche des processus électoraux
dans plusieurs pays de l'espace
francophone nous sommes allés d'ailleurs
sur des champs autre que le champ
africain dans le domaine politique nous
avons accompagné des processus dans un
pays observateur le Mozambique nous
avons accompagné l'Arménie nous avons
récemment à travers mon envoyé spécial
accompagné la Bosnie
erzégovine et donc le travail que
l'organisation doit faire sur le plan
politique et sur le champ démocratique
on fait bien ce travail on est sur la
désinformation qui est un fléau dans
beaucoup de pays et qui affectent bien
évidemment l'exercice de la démocratie
dans dans tous nos pays mais je ne peux
pas empêcher à
aux personnes qui ont certaines opinions
de garder leurs opinions personnellement
ça ça ne me ça ne me j'allais dire ça ne
m'empêche pas de dormir je fais le
travail qu'il faut et sur le terrain
dans tous ces pays-là dans les les
réunions les organisations soeurs qui
travaillent avec nous le travail
politique de l'if en faveur de la
démocratie ne s'est jamais arrêtée nous
avons et moi personnellement fait un
plaidoyer très fort sur la question de
la peine de mort avec deux pays
aujourd'hui qui ont aboli depuis que je
suis à la tête de l'organisation avec
des moratoires sur la peine de mort sur
les mariages précoces sur la
participation des femmes dans dans
l'exercice de la politique de leur pays
et donc
les critiques sont là pour nous aider à
nous améliorer mais personnellement je
pense que
moi même à la tête de l'organisation sur
les questions démocratiques je pense que
pour ceux qui sont honnêtes il y a quand
même un très bon bilan merci Madame
général d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis sur nos deux chaînes RFI France
[Musique]